all right let's get started scully
where are you on digitizing the old case
files as of yesterday i'm officially one
percent done
why are you smiling that's nothing well
there's thousands of cases and for each
one i have to fill out 200 little box
thingies on 50 different screens at
least you get to sit on your butt all
day
that's actually the worst part my doctor
said i have an anal canyon
scully why are you always telling us
about your disgusting body
i don't see anything that's because it's
all work
i am so sick of this city i go into a
coffee shop and as soon as everybody
sees that i'm a cop they stop talking
and they avoid eye contact with me
one lady even walked out i am just so
tired of being treated like the enemy
hey hitchcock your penis is hanging out
oh that's a relief there's no easy way
to put this sarge but someone
has been painting weiners on squad cars
and apparently
they won't stop until there's a penis
drown on every cop car in brooklyn
oh that's what he's been drawing but
what are those two little round things
at the bottom
it's the butt the what
oh emergency hitchcock they're stealing
brown bitty freeze
get your hands off the couch whoa whoa
whoa calm down we're getting a new one
we finally got some money to spruce up
the break room what the break room's
perfect the way it is
it's so comfortable and relaxed i can
put my butter feet on any surface in
there
exactly it's disgusting which is why
we're fixing it
hey jakey the place on the corner is
serving lemonade and you get to keep the
jar
it's pretty cool yes
that's very cool scully will you excuse
me just one moment oh sure
guys guys guys scully has a mason jar
full of lemonade
you called us in here to tell us that no
i called you in here to change your
lives
for you see a mere five minutes ago
hitchcock introduced me to his new
goldfish who lives in
oh an identical mason jar oh this isn't
gonna
end well there are two possible outcomes
and we're gonna bet on which one happens
first
so will hitchcock put fish food in
scully's lemonade or will skelly drink
hitchcock's goldfish
now you would think that putting fish
food into lemonade hitchcock just drank
his own fish
what no
nine hours and 55 minutes is it i feel
like i just sat down
i have no feeling down here whatsoever
i haven't in years according to a recent
study the physical
act of smiling can improve your mood i
suggest we give it a shot
now you all try
big smiles bigger bigger
great now we just have to stay like this
for the next two hours can you feel it
working i don't have any enamel on my
teeth so the cold air is excruciating
maybe if you brushed your teeth once in
a while this wouldn't be a problem
i do brush my teeth they're decaying
from acid reflux
you're embarrassing yourself you're like
you're not australian gina get stuffed
you drongo
guys seriously too much exposure to air
and they will turn to dust
this isn't working out as well as i'd
hoped time for the next level
forced laughing
[Laughter]
he's here okay he's here everybody be
cool hitchcock why do you have your
shirt off can't spill food on your shirt
if you're not wearing one
sarge captain no you guys brought
hitchcock oh
no we just bumped into him in the lobby
we don't know why he's here jenny
baby i love what prison's doing to your
figure
okay so how's prison you know what
really chafes my crack
we spent years crafting that break room
into something special something
comfortable
a place with so many stains that the new
ones just blended in where the couch
cushions were so
worn down they comforted all buds large
or
small flat or juicy juicy gross we built
a masterpiece and new amateurs flushed
it down the toilet
skirplash was that supposed to be a
flushing sound skirt
oh i am so sorry excuse me
oh my god it's like a she scully i'm hi
uh norm uh who are you chats
cindy shacks scully shake her hand oh oh
here i go
me to please you [ __ ] your hands are so
clammy i hate a bunch of clams earlier
and they still smell
yeah that's not what she meant no it was
hey sarge uh package was delivered to my
desk downstairs addressed to the 99th
precinct
attention sergeant but it's not for me
it's a book
sounds like something you'd order how to
please your wife 100 tips to take your
sex life from blah to uh
yeah that's not mine it also shipped
with two gallons of protein powder well
i get my protein from real food 22 meals
a day one every 40 minutes
it's not a big deal okay just take the
book i promise i won't tell anyone
hey sarge i heard you need some sex tips
except for the people i already told
here's the big one just lie flat on your
back women love to do all the work
ah that's very incorrect and i don't
need sex tips okay before we get going
sergeant jeffress has suggested that it
would improve morale if we started the
meeting with some consensual non-work
jabber
i just said it might be nice if you
checked in on the squad's personal lives
every now and then
exactly jabber scully go well it's just
a regular morning for me woke up again
with my dog's butt on my mouth
this experiment has failed hitchcock
there's a woman here interviewing
detectives as part of the commissioner's
selection process
all right i'll go hide in the janitor's
closet until this is all over thanks for
the heads up no it's too late for that
she wants to talk to you what
no how could you let this happen i'm not
calm down man
we just took her on a tour of the
precinct and now she's at lunch that
means we have one hour to teach you how
to behave like a human
oh i see you're gonna my bear lady me
my bear lady i'm assuming it's a my fair
lady porn parody
oh my we've got our work cut out for us
here's our list of words to avoid
chick foxy jew throb is grendel on the
table no
it's not on the table practice
introducing yourself hello
i'm detective michael hitchcock oh nice
job
why your hand so wet trick question the
answer's disgusting so i shouldn't tell
her
just don't have wet hands man
hey you dum-dums ice cream moose tracks
ice cream
how do you know yep it's definitely ice
cream
knew it they're going down also whoever
used this spoon
their body ain't right okay let's say it
is ice cream but i didn't need it i
couldn't have
i'm lactose intolerant me too i'm super
lactose in color
you're lying have you ever seen us eat
dairy you know no one can bear to watch
you eat
okay unlike kooky charles and tearful
terry i am healthy and don't need
therapy i hear that i don't go to
therapy either
jake and i are like two penises in a pod
damn it hitchcock we talked about this
it never helps when you back me up
sorry guys we're stuck with a nice clean
expensive sofa
but i guess we'll just have to make do
oh we'll make do we'll make do all over
it
well i just mean we'll fix it hells yeah
we will
should we wake them nah let them sleep
they aren't good
it's here she's here cindy schatz is
here what do i do
my face is so wet and my mouth is so dry
okay calm down
remember be direct women don't like to
play a lot of games
i think we got to start simpler okay
scully smile at her
don't fart he knows not to oh you're
writing that down
this is good stuff what else you got
don't talk about your foot fungus don't
talk about your eye fungus let's just
say fungus is off the table
oh no see you just wrote the word fungus
down and i feel like we're barreling
towards a misunderstanding
draw a circle around it and then put a
line through it there you go
believe in yourself be confident you're
a sweet guy with a big heart that's the
size of a giraffe's
pushes on my other organs okay you got
this don't talk about the dry part all
right
get out of here you got the book
[Music]
you should know things are good with
sharon i just want to make sure we're as
happy in our relationship as we can be
that's nice sarge sorry you had to
embarrass yourself not a big deal
i guess i just don't care what other
people think of me that's actually
pretty inspiring
i wish i was more like that yeah i don't
feel excuse me
whoa whoa hey hey you're not gonna wait
for me to leave like i said
i just don't care
guys horrible news the fridge broke this
morning everything's warm doesn't seem
like that big a deal your yogurt's
spoiled who did this
okay everyone calm down i will put a
request in for a new fridge good luck
getting that approved mr kelly's already
slashed our budget within an inch of its
life yeah the toilet paper's only one
ply now it buttered all the time the ac
is broken my butt hurts all the time
scully's butt hurts all the time right
guys we get it
we're here to apologize i can't prove
you took my moose strikes so i shouldn't
have yelled at you
i'm impressed it takes a big person to
admit when they're being a total dumb
dumb
we want to make it up to you we got you
a pizza only one pizza for both of us
oh my god that was an obvious setup you
morons
you're eating cheese you're lying about
being lactose intolerant no we weren't
some things are just delicious enough to
suffer the consequences
i'm diabetic but i still eat sugar out
of the bag oh just admit
you took my moose tracks admit it
admit it
yeah we ate it and we're eating your
pizza
so who's the [ __ ] now
ooze
they admitted it that's a victory right
no terry
there are no winners
move
here
you